こんにちわぁぁ！！はじめしゃちょーです。
大坂でUUUMの
イベントのう祭りというのがあるんですけども、う祭りの会場には
もうその、youtuberのファンとか応援しにきている方が、
沢山居て、会場はもう
人であふれているわけです。けど、
僕はその会場を歩きたい。歩きたいんだけども、
ダメって言われるんですよ…。こんな僕にすら、こう来て下さる方
がいるんで、僕が行くとこうパニックになるから、ちょっと僕は
行かないで下さいみたいな事言われていまして、僕はそのう祭りの
皆がいる所に行くことすらできない！！！僕はステージにしか
行けないんですよぉ！！うあぁぁぁぁぁ！！！
(拳に力を入れています。しばらくお待ちください）
何とかしたい！
何とかして、会場に入りたい…。もっと
もっと、近い距離でしちょーしゃしゃさんに会いたいんでしゅ
じぇしゅしょ
この姿だと皆気づいてしまうので、この姿だと会場に入れない。なので今回、僕はちょっと偽りの
姿で、
ふっｗ。
偽りの姿で会場に潜入して
その偽りの姿が結構僕とは分かりずらいと思うんですよ
動画で一回見せた偽りの姿なんですけども、あんまり再生されていないので、皆知らないと思うんで、
知ってる人は知っていても多分僕が入っているとは思わないんで、その偽りの姿でUUUMのイベントの
会場に行って、どれだけバレずに楽しめるのか
そもそもこのエビ…。
偽りの姿の僕を見て、皆ははじめしゃちょーと気づくのか、検証していきたいと思います。ではっ！！
はじめ）ありがとっ
？？）行ってらっしゃい
ンダホ）これ分かんないよ。分かんない×２
マサイ）これは分かんないよ
はじめ）分かんない？
はじめ）じゃあ行ってくよぉ！！
一同）いってらっしゃ～い
では行ってきます
＼！！デデ――ン！！／
女性スタッフ）いや分かるなぁ多分
グキィ（効果音
～戦闘的音楽～
～戦闘的音楽再び～
女性視聴者）はじめんの動画に居た！
～焦る感のある効果音～
～戦闘的音楽また～
ポンッ♩
~戦闘的音楽再び～
♩刺さる音♩
♪刺さる音♪
恐ろしい（？）効果音
～戦闘的音楽また～
キラリン♪
～騒ぎ始める周りの方達～
ついにファンがピークに…！
今回字幕が少なくて申し訳ございません…。けど、頑張った方なのでお許しください…。
今夜のニュースです
12日午後6時ごろ羽田発大坂行の全日空37便が機内の気圧が急激に低下したとして
羽田空港に引き返し、20分後に緊急着陸した。
全日空によると、当時、機体は上昇しながら飛行中で、異変に気づいた機長が客室に酸素マスクを出したという。
けが人はいなかった。全日空は、機内の圧力を一定に保つシステムに異常があった可能性があるとみて、原因を調べている。（yahooニュースより）
男性スタッフ）押さないでください×２
女性達）キャア―――！！！！
the end